I'm not gonna go in a closet with the
lights out or anything what this is an
Eyes Wide Shut hi I'm Kelsey and this is
my mom hi I'm Christie Kelsey's mom
that's what I do said Oh
least I Know Who I am today we're gonna
get handcuffed together for 24 hours
what what what what our relationship I
think is a normal relationship of no
it's normal we talk about sex and butt
stuff all the time in that normal I
think we are really always think she's
like my best friend not really a mom a
professional mother with a professional
daughter can talk about anything you can
call me well you can't call me anytime
I'm available from about 8 o'clock I
think the hardest thing is gonna be
actually being around each other when we
hang out we always say that we have a
shelf life of three days this could be
it this could be the breaking point your
hands really right now this very minute
yeah wait do I got to do anything it
doesn't matter because I'm coming with
you wait wait wait I don't take my watch
off and I did mine say I kind of feel
like trapped you carried me for nine
months you make the chain a little bit
longer
no they're handcuffs i cuffed you
[ __ ] oh no all righty let's go I
need to grab the wheel she's talked me
into getting micro blading done so
they're gonna cut a bunch of slices and
our eyebrows and then pour die in those
slides you coulda just said we're going
to get Michael a dish oh you go put your
seat belt on
well if I get have to get strapped in
with one more thing this is what that
claustrophobic thing is all about
there's a lot of fun cows I feel like
everyone thinks being chained to their
mom would be like a little sweet thing
like she'd do everything for you and
scratch your back where it's like being
chained to her is just like being in a
conference called a well you might learn
something we have given up on driving so
he finally decided to give me a bird she
doesn't like hanging out with me well in
doses mom's gonna talk to her assistant
tell her what we're doing today hey well
listen I'm I just wanted to make sure he
got the last contract that I was working
on last night yeah we made it to the
grove now we just have to go to Vince
and exchange my shoes
so
how do we okay I gotta get my strip off
I think I knew crow through my whole
know my eyebrows ideal here's the thing
is like you see meaning there many times
it's not like we have any shame I think
it's just not ideal
my legs well what you got shake your
legs for you just go into bed that's a
good point I am I get laid in the next
24 so we realized that showering was way
too [ __ ] hard so instead of mom
showering we found a pretty good
alternative but don't keep that on my
eyebrows try shampoo instead it's like a
shower in my mouth every day before I go
to bed you know that I like to do yoga
like a little bit of light stretching
and meditation to wind down for the day
but this is not very zen let's do some
stretching
we might end up clear what that means no
that is that you pull what don't mean in
the face there's modulates
instead of one where we can put our
backs together
what is this doing exactly bonding this
crap 9:30 on greedily down and turn off
the lights and Schumacher is super easy
to do shares but they have to do
anything
[Music]
finally now she can sleep my mom gets up
at 7:00 a.m. so I guess I'm getting up
at 7 a.m. to work I'm Jane
ball-and-chain
doing advice for us to last the last
couple of insane hours you know we found
that it was the most comfortable way to
make it not hurt your wrist is the whole
pants and I don't hold your hand
arguably the least hardest thing we've
done this is actually quite easy to do
they're all these fans you want to see
where you sleep no my mom's not so much
in a crunch oh you've been to a drug
show oh yeah I get around
it's a brunch is nice because we can get
like
you ever do this this [ __ ] hurts and
she won't get off her phone
I feel good an angry mom it's like put
your phone down oh it's like we're
married but my spouse doesn't want to be
married right like the others neurotic
women some backup has arrived
as long as we can still drink this you
feel like you learned anything new about
me not at all I know who you are
same for us it's just showing a
different dichotomy of what a a mom and
daughter can be what's wrong women the
very wrong
yeah and like that's okay we're both
very independent self-reliant women but
what this forced us to do was to slow
down to mentally thankful he's super
mindful and see like what the other
person needed it was less about us
connecting emotionally and more about us
learning how to have patience and
tolerance for one another
I think he's [ __ ] handcuffs on
freedom hey it up I can't thank Moms
what I can breathe love ya they love me
oh yeah I love you too honey
[ __ ] I'm getting out of here I have such
bad eye I can leave yay
[Music]